[Music]
okay
what did you spend your first biggest
commission paycheck on i paid my
girlfriend had a credit card at that
time i paid that offer and then went to
the pub and spent it and then was broke
again within a week
what non-negotiable would you live by
each day do you feel has a massive
impact on your productivity and helps
you maximize each day recruitment being
on time give yourself some time to
settle in today and then just make sure
that get started at the right time what
has been the most pointless kpi that you
maybe have had yourself in the past or
you've heard recruiters have
cool times i like obviously you've got
to be on the phone but
one of the pointless things about it is
that people then i've seen people just
having the phone off the hook just so
they can hit their two hours so i can go
home or i like calling the talking clock
so don't know if it drives the right
behaviors but it's important to be on
the phone
how do you think we can change the
perception of the recruitment industry
by becoming actual solutions partners
delivering outcomes having business
conversations not transactional uh
spammy
approach just yeah just you've got to
change we've got to change that
[Music]
you